look at that sexy [ __ ] oh damn i
[ __ ] one of them bro
i'll tell you that i'm not going to tell
you which one all right
[Laughter]
how am i bringing theo home how long
have you been with her
we've been married for about five years
now so my best friend for what thank you
dude i'm married
and i'm so proud of myself you know the
cool thing was i was like
touring living in like a 97 uh
high top southern comfort van and was
like
ass broke when i met her and she was
like a vegas girl that was like you know
working and she had like
[ __ ] a penthouse condo like two
sports cars and
i could not believe that we ended up and
what did you guys mean we met at a show
she came to one of your shows she was
with some abusive douchebag
they came to his show and we were
backstage and i knew that dude was a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and uh they split and i just i'm not
gonna act like i shot my shot she kind
of shot hers
and i was she's playing your dm's yeah
yeah well now we have mutual friends so
she was like yo just plug me in with
jelly
and i hit her on some other [ __ ] i was
like yo i'm trying to come out there and
shoot and shoot some content some video
stuff she's like yeah come on
i was like oh well i live in my van so
i'll leave now
on my way my videographer fly out and
uh you know the first night i slept on
the couch the second night i i slept in
her
dancing but the true
love story though he's got a leak it's a
white trash love story
and you know we got married kind of
randomly it was a yellow wolf deftone
concert
oh hell yeah right and i went on stage
and asked her to marry me and we can it
was vegas right so it's like 11 o'clock
they're closing the joint down by hard
rock
and uh i'm like [ __ ] it let's just go
now she's like the courthouse is open
for 35
44 more minutes i was like that's
[ __ ] wrong we wouldn't get married
midnight the city yeah because that's
famous in vegas
10 p.m it's a split this is a quick
decision yeah oh yeah we listen to bruno
mars mirror you the whole way there
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
i think i was doing coke or xan actually
you got to be doing some codes to get
married after 10.
yeah yeah but we started out we were
like the story nobody thought and she's
my best friend man she really
that's so cool she supported me she
helped me get my music career really up
and
up and going going you know she yeah you
need somebody to support you to somebody
to tell you everything's going to be all
right a lot of times you know yeah
that's true
that's big to him she also helped on the
other end you know [ __ ] she helped me
like financially like i was the people
always look at her like she's a gold
digger i was like y'all have no [ __ ] i
got close
dead broke around her dude but before
you got married was that life on the
road where you were you yeah it's
trouble right yeah you know how that is
dog
you remember the 200 shows man yeah you
know what i'm saying when you're like
i'm getting
brendan doesn't went straight to like
two thousand dollar shows
yeah did you go straight to the thousand
did you ever do the two hundred dollar
joint yeah oh dude
but i but yeah but i i did fight for
pennies yeah
i remember having no salt for my food
and crying on my [ __ ] salmon
oh yeah i did have salmon though
that's not all bad anyway we were doing
180 shows a year for like 100 bucks a
show too
200 bucks was like my max money yeah and
i'm like
one of four on for opening for like
three rock bands yeah doing rap and like
getting a hundred bucks and selling
150 in t-shirts that night and hopping
in my little van and
rolling on some nights we just sleep at
truck stops before you met her though
because you you're you're still famous
right merch was it merch is what did it
merch is what usually helped a lot of
times
yeah selling cds after and that's what
changed a lot with when things got
digital you just couldn't sell merch
anymore
well t-shirts are cool i'll give you i
hope you got some gear for y'all but
it's like
we uh my my philosophy was just always
like if i can set up a merch booth
to this day right if somebody called me
i was like yo will you open up for
brantley gilbert
i'm answering yes and not even asking
about the money
you know they could say well we only got
100 bucks no problem can i set up merch
yep
yeah for sure i'm opening for brandley
tell them i'm there you know i don't
care of you
how about i'll give you five hundred
dollars to let me open up for bradley
gilbert yeah i can set up a t-shirt
oh i merged at a damn funeral dude back
in the day yeah you know i'll find an
album quickly
yeah where they cry oh yeah cause you
was in the air where you all sold the
actual specials on desk
dude i used to buy the disc changer i'd
bring it with me in my bag i'd set up my
hotel room i'd go by the disc at the
target then i'd stack them in there it
was a three disc
burner at once burn i remember those
three at once
and slide them in the plastic it would
get so loud by the end of the day
because you'd run it like two thousand
times in a row would you sell them off
the spindles i sell them off the spindle
bruh i remember this yeah
obama just grabbed this [ __ ] you still
have some of those i should claim that
[ __ ]
yeah oh i'll sell you one right now
we'll have next in the money
[Music]
is